es ist die beratung mehrerer vorlagen
zur modernisierung des
telekommunikationsrechts
für die aussprache ist eine dauer von 30
minuten geschlossen
ich höre auf die aussprache das war den
kollegen andreas lämmel cdu csu
[Applaus]
präsident meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren man könnte sozusagen sagen es ist
vollbracht das tkg wird also heute hier
im deutschen bundestag verabschiedet und
ich finde das ist eine gute sache
zum einen für die
telekommunikationsbranche und zum
anderen aber auch für die verbraucher
die kunden in unserem land am 16.12 hat
es die bundesregierung hat den
gesetzentwurf auf den tisch gelegt und
eigentlich sollte am 21
dezember schon die frist in brüssel
ablaufen das praktisch der kodex für zur
elektronischen kommunikation
verabschiedet werden sollte
das war natürlich nicht zu schaffen gar
keine frage aber schaut man mal was in
europa sich bisher getan hat muss man ja
feststellen dass bisher nur drei länder
überhaupt diesen kodex umgesetzt haben
das ist finnland ungarn und griechenland
und dass wir heute am 22 april
unsere tkkg modernisierungsgesetz damit
auch dieses projekt diese kodex
umsetzung beschließen da liegen wir also
als deutschland schon ganz gut im
zeitplan
meine damen und herren sie zu den zielen
dieser europäischen richtlinien gehörte
ja unter anderem dass wir das mehr
wahlmöglichkeiten und rechte für
verbraucher eingeräumt werden sollten
dass wir in europa effizientere notruf
verbindungen organisieren müssen und was
für uns auch sehr wichtig war dass wir
mehr anreize für investitionen in netze
mit sehr hoher kapazität bekommen das
ist eigentlich auch dass kempter
kernpunkt unseres heutigen gesetzes und
nun haben wir aus unserer sicht und ich
glaube das sind wir uns in der koalition
oder hier im hohen haus auch einig diese
ziele mit dieser novellierung auch
erreichen können
die studie eine studie des pk zum
deutschen kommunikationsmarkt im
internationalen vergleich fördert hier
schon einige interessante punkte hervor
die sehr relevant sind auch für unsere
gesetzgebungsverfahren nehmen nämlich
deutscher liegt bei der besetzung mit
breitbandanschlüssen das lächelt gar
nicht so schlecht circa 88 prozent der
haushalte in deutschland warten also
zugriff auf einen breitbandanschluss
aber wenn man danach schaut aber sagen
und diese situation wird dadurch
erreicht zum einen durch die fernseh
kabelnetze dann zum anderen durch die
vectoring und super factory und
maßnahmen mit der letzten jahre schaut
man aber genauer hin also was sind die
class was ist die penetration mit
glasfaseranschlüssen da wird das defizit
in deutschland deutlich sichtbar denn
nur zehn prozent der haut
in deutschland hatten zugriff auf einen
glasfaseranschluss und meine damen und
herren genau darum geht es ja das ist
eindeutig zu wenig um die gigabit
gesellschaft zu erreichen
und deswegen war es notwendig dass wir
hier telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz klarer maßnahmen
für einen beschleunigten glasfaserausbau
auch treffen
umso mehr hat mich eigentlich erstaunt
dass einer der großen der branche vor
zwei wochen ungefähr über die presse
mitteilen ließ dass er seine netze im
bereich der privaten haushalte also
diese coax kabelnetze nur ausbauen will
und keine glasfaser verlegen will also
ich halte das für eine falsche strategie
und deswegen war es auch notwendig dass
wir zum beispiel eines der kernpunkte
unseres gesetzes das thema der
betriebskostenumlage auch der umlage
fähigkeit deutlich verändert haben wir
wollen
meine damen und herren wir wollen den
ausbau mit glasfaser bis in jede wohnung
voranbringen
wir schaffen mit diesem gesetzentwurf
jetzt entsprechende voraussetzungen und
ich hoffe dass wir heute mit großer
mehrheit dieses tkg beschließen das ist
ein guter tag für die branche und das
ist ein guter tag für unser land vielen
dank
[Applaus]
der obmann für wirtschaft und energie
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion in der
debatte zum telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz uns liegt noch
keine trinkender liste vor wie ein könig
ist jetzt hier von der afg er antwortet
als erstes auf andreas lämmel sehr der
präsident sehr geehrte kollegen liebe
zuschauer auf den tribünen und an den
bildschirm
die regierung hat einen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt der die telekommunikation
modernisieren soll wie ich vor sieben
wochen in erster lesung sagte es geht
voran aber in trippelschritten
zum ersten mal werden dienste und
leistungsmerkmale mit einem funktionalen
ansatz beschrieben und so wörtlich nicht
allein mit einem technischen ansatz
damit hängt die bundesregierung auch nur
etwa zehn jahre hinter dem markt her
denn die funktionale beschreibung von
diensten und leistungsmerkmalen hat sich
schon lange durchgesetzt am markt wie
soll man auch sonst technologieoffen
beschreiben was man als leistung haben
möchte dann noch etwas positives meine
anregung den begriff netze mit sehr
hoher kapazität funktionaler und
technologie offener zu beschreiben
ja diese anregung wurde umgesetzt es
gibt nicht nur glasfaser
leider stehen aber wieder keine
konkreten angaben zum bandbreiten und
verfügbarkeit liegen bis er im
gesetzentwurf die wirkliche musik spielt
also weiterhin in den anhängen zum
gesetz und in den allgemeinverfügung und
festlegungen der bundesnetzagentur
es gibt wie schon erwähnt bei einigen
kollegen die eine vorliebe für glasfaser
fragen sie doch einfach mal bei
verschiedenen größeren sparkassen nach
viele haben nämlich fiber to the desk
wieder herausgerissen weil kein power
over ethernet möglich war
ja das ist die die praktische erfahrung
und mit dieser fixierung auf eine
technologie erinnern sie mich an ihre
scholle cardia meinte auch mit einer
einzigen technologie hätte er den
finalen durchbruch geschafft den 1
megabit chip damals das finale sei aber
völlig anders aus die freiheit kamen und
freiheit brauchen wir auch im
technologie und
telekommunikationsbereich
die bundeskanzlerin mag auch keine
freiheit und hat daher die it und den
breitbandausbau in den jahren 2010 2012
20 17 also dreimal zur chefsache erklärt
wieder so ein versuch dass staatlicher
technologie durchbruch was aber ist in
dieser zeit real passiert im jahre 1999
hat siemens mobile einen großauftrag aus
china erhalten für den aufbau eines
mobilfunknetzes
heute müssen wir uns hier in deutschland
überlegen ob wir uns einem chinesischen
chinesischen staatskonzern hurerei
ausliefern wollen um moderne
mobilfunknetze zu erhalten
wir haben lange davor gewarnt von
siemens mobile aber ist schon lange
keine rede mehr
im breitbandausbau liegen wir in europa
auf platz 25 helmel hinter
wirtschaftsmächten wie slowenien und
lettland
was für ein armutszeugnis für die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt der
bundesregierung es tut mir leid ihnen
sagen zu müssen dass lassen sie mal
lieber sie können das nämlich gar nicht
was hier unter anderem brauchen ist eine
definierte ausfallsicherheit denn seit
der umstellung auf die ip telefonie sind
bei stromausfall auch automatisch die
telefone der endkunden tot
früher war das besser und da müssen wir
auch wieder hin dass die telefonie auch
bei stromausfall funktioniert nicht
jeder wie nicht jeder hat ein
mobiltelefon
glauben sie mir bei dieser energiewende
sind die stromausfälle garantiert im
abschnitt zwei des gesetzentwurfs zur
notfallvorsorge hätte man also eine
ausfallsicherheit beziehungsweise
verfügbarkeit festlegen müssen die
strafen wenn ein öffentlicher
netzbetreiber die pflichten der
notfallvorsorge aus dem § 183 ford
folgende verletzt sind mit maximal eine
million euro auch viel zu geringen das
sind peanuts für solche unternehmen dem
gesetzentwurf unter insgesamt fünf
anträge bei gestellt wir werden
sachbezogen abstimmen zustimmen ablehnen
und enthalten lassen sie sich
überraschen
den gesetzentwurf aber in seiner
heutigen form lehnen wir ab
es ist zu wenig
viel zu spät und nochmal liebe
bundesregierung ihre bilanz nach drei
mal chefsache
platz 25 im breitbandausbau zweitens es
gibt keine einheitlichen
telekommunikationshersteller mehr
drittens ist durch die die reale gefahr
von china technologisch abhängig zu
werden und viertens von den usa sind wir
bereits heute technologisch abhängig sie
können es einfach nicht man könnte
meinen sie zerstören planvoll die
infrastruktur die leistungsfähigkeit
deutschlands
vielen dank koenig von der afg er ist
mitglied im ausschuss digitale agenda
der bundestag debattiert ja die
einzelnen gesetzesvorhaben in kleiner
besetzung und auch relativ schnell und
zügig deswegen sind die redebeiträge
anders als früher meistens nur drei bis
vier minuten
nächster redner angekündigt falko mohrs
von der spd auch leer wie der vor
rentner johann könig af.de mitglied im
ausschuss digitale agenda falko mohrs
von der spd sehr geehrter herr präsident
meine damen und herren
ach ja hierher könig also was soll man
da noch sagen ich meine wir wussten dass
die ard ist nicht so richtig mit zukunft
und gegenwart hat sondern irgendwie noch
vor allem jahrzehnten stehen geblieben
ist das ist mir glasfaser nicht haben
das haben wir jetzt auch verstanden
ich bin ja schon fast froh jetzt hat der
kollege wirtschaftsausschuss dann auch
gesagt 450 seiten gesetz ist zu
kompliziert da könnte man gar nichts zu
sagen das kann man alltag die nicht
verarbeiten hoffentlich haben sie
gestern gelesen nicht verstanden
gut so ist es wir widmen uns der debatte
meine damen und herren
kommunikationsinfrastruktur moderne
leistungsfähige
kommunikationsinfrastruktur ist das
nervensystem unserer gesellschaft und es
ist die voraussetzung für teilhabe und
es ist die voraussetzung für einen
wirtschaftlichen erfolg in unserem land
und deswegen ist es wichtig und es ist
notwendig dass wir heute mit dem
telekommunikations modernisierungsgesetz
und genau diesen ziel in einer
hochleistungsfähigen einer modernen
der zukunftsgerichteten infrastruktur in
unserem land mehr und deswegen ist es
ein gutes gesetz meine damen und herren
wir verglast fasern das land wie ver
glasfasern die infrastruktur bis in die
wohnung und deswegen ist es gut dass wir
die jahrzehntealte auf koaxialkabel
ausgelegte umlage fähigkeit und den
mietswohnung auch jetzt in richtung
einer leistungsfähigen glasfaser
infrastruktur modernisieren
es wird eben in zukunft zu sein dass
dort wo neue glasfaserinfrastruktur in
mietwohnungsbau eingebaut wird eine in
der dauer begrenzte und vor allem auch
in der höhe auf 5 euro im monat
begrenzte umlage für diese neue
glasfaser infrastruktur geschaffen wird
das heißt also dass insbesondere auch
dort wo bisher der glasfaserausbau nicht
stattgefunden hat bei den mieterinnen
und mietern in den wohnungen dass dort
eben jetzt seine puls in den nächsten
jahren zu erwarten ist und das schaffen
wir eben mit genau dieser
gesetzesvorlage meine damen und herren
das ganze auch in verbindung mit
wechsels also mehr wahlfreiheit und mehr
wettbewerb und eben ich habe es gesagt
in der höhe der umlage so dass es auch
sozial verträglich ist
wir setzen davon bin ich fest überzeugt
in fragen des verbraucherschutzes
maßstäbe wir haben es geschafft dass
dann wenn ein vertrag nämlich endet er
nicht mehr automatisch sich um ein oder
zwei jahre verlängert sondern dann nur
noch eine monatliche verlängerung damit
für die verbraucherinnen verbraucher
auch monatlich kündbar ist also die
ärgerliche endlosschleife von lang
vertragsverlängerung gehört mit dieser
gesetzesnovelle der vergangenheit an
meine damen und herren
außerdem muss der verbraucher in zukunft
rechtzeitig und schriftlich darauf
hingewiesen werden dass eben jetzt seine
kündigung stattfinden muss außerdem hat
der kunde rechte beispielsweise werden
die versprochene
buchte und bezahlte bandbreite nicht
geliefert wird das dann eben auch
minderungsrecht in den monatlichen raten
dazu gehören der kunde hat das recht das
ab dem zweiten kalendertag an entweder
eine entstörung stattgefunden hat seines
anschlusses oder aber auch dort
minderungsrecht für den kunden
bestehende alte meine damen und herren
gesetzen hier maßstäbe beim
verbraucherschutz und bevor gleich tabea
rößner wieder die sorge kommt vielleicht
einfach mal reingucken jetzt gesetz die
zwölf monats verträge gehören zum
standard mit dazu da steht nämlich dass
dem kunden vor vertragsabschluss ein
zwölf monats vertrag angeboten werden
muss und dann ist es eben auch die
entscheidung des kunden ob er eben genau
diesen weg des 12 monats vertrags oder
eines längeren vertrages geht das meine
damen und herren ist daneben auch
verbraucherschutz dass der kunde sich
hier entscheiden kann
wir haben also neben die in zukunft
richten und frage einer modernen eine
hochleistungsfähige infrastruktur den
maßstäben beim kunden schutz ist auch
geschafft dass wir in fragen der inneren
sicherheit weil es ja hier so manche ich
nenne das dann immer feuchten träume
offensichtlich der sicherheitsbehörden
gegeben hat die haben wir die augen
machte warten nämlich dass das was in
der vergangenheit möglich war
auch unter betrachtung der
internationale standard in 95 g netz
möglich ist nichts mehr
wir haben nicht entgegen der aussagen
die gestern auch gefallen wurde nichts
im bereich der vorratsdatenspeicherung
geändert dies weiter ausgesetzt meine
damen und herren in fragen der
bestandsdaten das ist reingekommen ist
des bundesrates braucht die grünen
zugestimmt haben also meine damen und
herren ist ein gutes gesetz ist hoch
leistungsfähig es schafft die
voraussetzung ich bitte um zustimmung
herzlichen dank ja so war es mit den
feuchten träumen der sicherheitsbehörden
zusammen mit dem telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz was immer er damit
gemeint hat sollte wahrscheinlich
phantasie anregen
der nächste redner kommt von der fdp aus
dem ausschuss wirtschaft und energie es
geht ja nicht nur um die digitale agenda
es geht ja auch leitungsstrukturen
investition also ist auch die wirtschaft
engstens beteiligt meine damen und
herren ende 2018 hat die europäische
union der bundesregierung zwei jahre
zeit gegeben die richtlinie zum kodex
für die elektronische kommunikation
umzusetzen
ziel ist es und war es wohlweislich
markt getrieben ausbau der digitalen
infrastruktur voran zu bringen
es geht also um nicht mehr oder weniger
als um die frage wie sieht es aus mit
der digitalisierung in deutschland knapp
vor ablauf dieser zwei jahre ging dann
2020 der referentenentwurf ins kabinett
erste lesung hat mir dann ende januar
ist es berichtet wurde dann war
funkstille
und dann bekamen wir diesen dienstag
keine 24 stunden vor der
ausschusssitzung keine 48 stunden vor
dieser debatte hier im plenum einen
änderungsantrag über 450 seiten der kam
so um die ecke
meine damen und herren das ist eine
missachtung der opposition
und es ist eine missachtung des
parlamentarischen prozesses
und besonders ärgerlich finde ich dann
dass die koalition offensichtlich diese
informationen erst der presse und dann
einigen privatwirtschaftlichen
unternehmen zugesteckt hat und dann erst
uns alles parlamentarischen vertretern
wenn sie anderthalb stunden nachdem sie
450 seiten bekommen
schon die erste stellungnahme eines
privatwirtschaftlichen anbieters aus
diesem bereich bekommen der da sagt dass
wir gut daran dass hinüber schlecht
daran muss ich sagen fühle ich mich hier
sehr sehr gekränkt als parlament aber
meine damen und herren es geht um die
digitale zukunft unseres landes und in
dem prozess hatte ich das gefühl
manchmal hat man nur das interesse in
der regierung das wirklich schnell jetzt
hier über die bühne zu bringen
der kollege level hat gesagt es ist
erreicht
nun denn es gibt einige punkte in diesem
gesetz die begrüßen wir auch ich weiß es
gibt kein patent und kein anrecht auf
politische ideen aber die
fdp-bundestagsfraktion war die erste
fraktion die einen antrag eingebracht
hat die den vorschlag macht eine
verbindung herzustellen zwischen dem
nebenkosten privileg und der frage der
digitalisierung in die immobilien
deswegen an der stelle wo es mir das
gesetz aber wenn man insgesamt
betrachtet meine damen und herren 20
milliarden euro subventionen bis 2025
eine unklare definition zwischen weißen
und blauen flecken das ist wiederum eine
verschiebung ich habe es am anfang
gesagt weg von der privatwirtschaft hin
zur staatswirtschaft und deswegen können
wir insgesamt ihrem antrag und ihrem
gesetz leider nicht
folgen vielen dank soweit reinhard
gruppen von der fdp aus dem ausschuss
für wirtschaft und energie jetzt kommt
wieder jemand aus dem ausschuss digitale
agenda der 2 der ausschuss der in diesem
zusammenhang sehr wichtig ist uns war
die obfrau der linken
anke domscheit-berg hier sehen sie sie
bereits und sie ist jetzt gleich dran
vorher wird die am rednerpult kurz
desinfiziert alles nach dem krone regeln
des bundestages anke domscheit berg
sehr geehrte präsident liebe kolleginnen
wir debattieren das telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz das selbst dick
ist wie ein telefonbuch mit seinen über
450 seiten drei minuten redezeit reichen
nicht aus für fundierte kritik an der
immer noch verfassungswidrigen
vorratsdatenspeicherung und neue
überwachungsbefugnisse oder an zu langen
telekom vertragslaufzeiten und zu engen
vorgaben für regionales roaming ich
beschränke mich auf ein thema heute auf
den universaldienst als recht auf
schnelles internet
seit drei jahren ist die bundesregierung
in der pflicht dieses recht gesetzlich
zu verankern und europäisches recht
damit in nationales umzusetzen
unverbindlich versprochen wurde der
bevölkerung ein schnelles netz ja schon
recht oft 50 ende des ende 2008 10.000 m
wird bis 2025
wir alle wissen die realität sieht
völlig anders aus der fortschritt beim
breitbandausbau bleibt eine schnecke das
hatte in der pandemie und hat es auch
noch dramatische folgen für viele wir
konnten anfang des jahres zu alle live
die landung einer mars sonde live
verfolgen
aber die distanz unterricht von zu hause
konnten viele kinder nicht nur bei mir
im norden von brandenburg immer noch
nicht machen
viele erwachsene verzweifeln an den
stabilen videokonferenzen im home-office
verfehlte förderstrategie und an die
steuer an die chance blinder glaube
daran dass großkonzerne digitale
daseinsvorsorge vernünftig leisten
können bremsten den ausbau leider bringt
aber auch dieser gesetzentwurf nur einen
rechtsanspruch auf lames internet denn
aktuell genügen 56 kilobit pro sekunde
als funktionaler internetanschluss die
neunzigerjahre lassen freundlich grüßen
daraus wollte die groko im ersten
gesetzentwurf lächerliche 10 mbit machen
und hat erst im überarbeiteten
hof sich gesteigert ihren geringen
anspruch auf 30 endet immerhin sollen
jetzt die home office fähigkeit und
videostreaming in angemessenem umfang
nicht mehr als luxus gelten ernsthaft
coco mit dem vorliegenden antrag meiner
fraktion der linken wäre ein wirkliches
recht auf schnelles internet verankert
100 mbit für den download 50 mbit für
den upload und zwar egal ob man in der
lausitz im havelland oder auch in
oberhausen wohnt denn der zugang zu
digitaler daseinsvorsorge der darf nicht
davon abhängen ob ich auf dem land oder
in der stadt wohne
deshalb heißt das ja universaldienst
weil es sich technologie aber
weiterentwickelt wollen wir auch einen
rechtsanspruch auf einen gigabit
anschluss bis 2030 schaffen ich erinnere
daran die bundesregierung verspricht das
ja bereits für 2025 dann sollte das bis
2030 als rechtsanspruch wohl kein
problem sein
im übrigen haben informationen zu
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen nicht zum
strafrecht verloren § 209 10 a gehört
abgeschafft vielen dank meine damen und
herren sowie anke domscheit berg mit
ihrem redebeitrag jetzt kommt mit tabea
rößner
wenn sie die rednerin einer fraktion die
noch nicht dran war nämlich bündnis
90/die grünen liegt noch noch kleinste
fraktion im deutschen bundestag sie ist
sprecherin von netzpolitik und
verbraucherpolitik war ja auch vorhin im
phoenix-interview zu gast zu diesem
thema telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz unambitioniert so
das urteil der sachverständigen in der
anhörung und auch der überarbeitete
gesetzentwurf enttäuscht alle hoffnungen
auf eine moderne umsetzung des tk
kodexes dabei geht es hier um eine
zukunftsaufgabe nämlich die digitale
infrastruktur schneller und
verbraucherfreundlich auszubauen
stattdessen haben sie zwei jahre mit
streitereien zwischen den ministerien
verplempert verbände wurden mit absurd
kurzem äußerungsfrist vor den kopf
gestoßen und uns knallen wie vorgestern
umfangreichste änderungen vor die füße
eine fruchtbare und sache orientierte
beratung geht anders
inhaltlich sind die neuen vorschläge
kein großer wurf in teilen sogar ein
rückschritt 2009/10 kündigte die
bundesjustizministerin
das ende von zweijahresverträgen für
telefon handy oder internet an
das ist nun vom tisch und kollege mark
es müssen nur irgendwelche 12 monats
verträge angeboten werden ohne preis
deckelung diese werden also weiter nur
als alibi und unattraktiv angeboten
werden das ist der status quo und
deshalb ist es keine verbesserung des
verbraucherschutzes die neue regelung
für ein gedecktes glasfaser
bereitstellungsentgelt mag zwar besser
sein als eine modernisierungsumlage die
ja ewig auf die miete umgelegt werden
kann aber nur dann wenn die deckelung
nicht mitbegründeten mehrkosten leicht
ausgehebelt werden kann so wie es das
gesetz ermöglicht und alle nutzerinnen
sollten die vertraglich zugesicherte
datenübertragungsrate auch tatsächlich
bekommen dass es aktuell nur bei 16
prozent von ihnen der fall da reicht ihr
minderungsrecht überhaupt nicht deshalb
fordern wir einen pauschalierten
schadenersatzanspruch von fünf euro pro
tag genauso enttäuschend
die regelung zum universaldienst eine
minimale umsetzung der europäischen
vorgaben decoder pandemie zeigt doch was
dringlich ist nur mit schnellen und
verlässlichen internet können die
menschen am home office teilnehmen am
distanz unterricht oder digitale
verwaltungsleistungen die nutzen und
deshalb brauchen wir einen echten
rechtsanspruch auf schnelles internet
mit jährlich festgelegten
mindestbandbreite die immer und überall
zur verfügung stehen
diese muss sich daran orientieren was
die mehrheit der nutzerinnen tatsächlich
hat ihnen reicht es dagegen wenn eine
handvoll von diensten irgendwie halbwegs
funktionieren da platz doch ihr groß
angekündigtes recht auf intel schnelles
internet wie eine seifenblase das
sollten sie darauf wenigstens zu geben
der gesetzentwurf wird erhebliche
verfassungsrechtliche risiken und
stiftet mit parallel laufenden
gesetzesvorhaben verwirrungen es drohen
rechtsunsicherheit bei wirtschaft und
gefahr für das recht auf informationelle
selbstbestimmung also wenn sie schon
nicht auf uns hören dann wenigstens auf
den datenschutzbeauftragten sie müssen
sicherstellen dass wenn sie
datenschutzfragen aus tkg und tmg
herauslösen und in einem eigenen gesetz
regeln dass diese gesetze auch
gleichzeitig in kraft treten fielen dann
soweit tabea rößner von bündnis 90 die
grünen hier im bundestag
bei dieser gelegenheit vielleicht noch
eine ankündigung sie werden heute bis 18
uhr 30 im bundestag bleiben die ende
des abgeordnetengesetzes ist uns so
wichtig dass wir länger dabeibleiben
wir werden an den bundestag aber noch
verlassen dazu aber gleich noch mehr
zunächst unterricht lange
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der cdu/csu-fraktion beschäftigt sich
mit verkehr und digitale infrastruktur
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein
umfangreiches gesetzeswerk findet heute
seinen guten abschluss hier mit der
zweiten und dritten lesung und ich sage
zunächst allen kolleginnen und kollegen
und den beteiligten ministerien herr
bundesminister ein herzliches dankeschön
für die intensive zusammenarbeit die wir
da an der ein oder anderen stelle hatten
und es bewahrheitet sich einmal wieder
wie gut dass es uns hier im deutschen
bundestag gibt wenn die eine oder andere
änderung war noch dringend erforderlich
dankeschön liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja die koalition hat gezeigt
dass sie handlungsfähig ist das was wir
uns im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
haben setzen wir um neue frequenzen nur
gegen flächendeckende versorgung genau
das steht jetzt konkret so im gesetz
drin als mobilfunk ausbauziel 4g an den
straßen an den schienen ist keine kühe
4g ist muss und ist die basis für 5g in
der zukunft liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
[Applaus]
und wir haben nochmals den
instrumentenkasten nachgeschärft der
bundesnetzagentur
aber auch die spielregeln gegenüber den
netzbetreibern verändert und liebe
kollegen der fdp
wer nach 20 jahren missglückten
flächendeckenden ausbau von mobilfunk
vom markt redet der träumt ich kann das
nicht anders sagen als jemand aus dem
ländlichen raum hören sie endlich auf
mit der leier der marktwirtschaft bei
telekommunikation auf dem lande ich kann
ehrlich nicht mehr hören
denn denn es ist zwingend es ist
zwingend dass die tk betreiber
zusammenarbeiten
es wird kein paralleles netz geben
es rechnet sich nicht und deswegen ist
es auch gut dass wir mit einer
entsprechenden mobilfunk strategie der
bundesregierung in dieser periode eine
klare antwort gefunden haben
und eines haben wir auch gelernt hier
drin
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
und deswegen haben wir auch die rechte
des parlaments in der kontrolle
geschärft und die möglichkeiten zum
eingriff denn wir haben gelernt aus den
letzten versteigerungen dass es keinen
sinn macht wenn man sich nur darauf
verlässt dass angeblich unabhängige
behörden das schon regeln werden
insgesamt also an dieser stelle eine
klare neujustierung des instrumenten
kassen noch ein satz zum universaldienst
der universaldienst sichert eine
grundversorgung er gewährleistet einen
grund versorgungsanspruch genau diese
gewährleistung steht im 87 ff unseres
grundgesetzes
ja die fähre zwischen stadt und land
darf nicht weiter aufgehen und genau an
dieser stelle setzen wir an ja wir
setzen an beim home office ja wir setzen
an beim homeschooling und deswegen haben
wir auch die kriterien von latenz und
upload rate ausdrücklich mit aufgenommen
in dieses gesetz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen kriterien
sind festgelegt kriterien sind zu
erfüllen
die verfahrens fristen sind verkürzt
der rahmen ist durchaus ambitioniert
aber wir wissen alle dass es erst 1
gesetzt ist
jetzt geht es an die tatsächliche
umsetzung und wir als gesetzgeber werden
uns schärfer als in der vergangenheit
anschauen was bundesnetzagentur und
telekommunikationsunternehmen an dieser
stelle leisten
sie können mehr als sie bisher gezeigt
haben dankeschön sagte langer von der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer was ich
gerade schon angekündigt habe 18 uhr 30
cent wie heute im bundestag grund ist
der tagesordnungspunkt änderung des
abgeordnetengesetzes kurz nach 17 uhr
ist er angekündigt
da geht es um wesentlich schärfer dort
brands regeln für die
bundestagsabgeordneten was ihre
nebeneinkünfte und ihre
unternehmensbeteiligung angeht
nächster redner gustav herzog von der
spd herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist heute ein historisches
datum weil exakt vor 40 jahren und zwei
wochen am 8 april 1981 hat sich das
kabinett helmut schmidt mit einem
konjunkturprogramm befasst und
bestandteil dieses programm war aufbau
eines integrierten breitband
glasfasernetzes vor 40 jahren
dann hat diese seite des hauses
versaubeutelt weil helmut kohl und die
damalige schwarz gelbe koalition sich
für den private kabelfernsehen
entschieden hat und diese
zukunftstechnologie glasfaser auf uns
warten musste deswegen das heute ein
historisches datum dass wir mit diesem
gesetz das klar faser wieder an die
stelle rücken wo es hingehört
ganz vorn hin weil es ein gehöriges
datums handel wie auch in vier
dimensionen der dimension wir vergraben
klar vom acker flug zum kabel flug das
geht jetzt richtig los die zweite
dimension wir vergleich fasern
wunderschönes wort auch die häuser und
ich bin meinem kollegen falko mohrs
herzlich dankbar dass wir in diesem
bereich uns wirklich durchgesetzt haben
und die schlichte abschaffung die die
regierung vorgesehen hat zu einem echten
investitionsanreiz für das glasfaser in
der wohnung geschaffen haben
dieser stelle will ich auch den
sachverständigen danken insbesondere
professor thomas seider hier wertvolle
hinweise geliefert hat die dritte
dimension
wir füllen den raum mit mobilfunk
kollege ulrich lange ja wir haben lange
um den 86 2 gestritten aber das ergebnis
kann sich sehen lassen wir gehen
ambitionierte schritte wir werden den
mobilfunk leistungsfähig ausbreiten
überall in der fläche und vor allen
dingen bei den verkehrswegen dafür wenn
wir unterwegs sind auch den kontakt zur
großen weiten welt nicht verlieren und
die vierte dimension
wir haben ambitionierte fristen gesetzt
bei den verbraucherverträgen verkürzt
bei den berichten an das parlament auf
genehmigung fiktionen eingeführt wenn
die kommunale verwaltung eben nicht
genehmigt dann darf gebaut werden
also wir haben da richtig gas gegeben
und einsatz noch zum universaldienst
liebe kolleginnen kollegen der nächste
deutsche bundestag für die große freude
haben sich jedes jahr mit diesem thema
aufgrund eines berichtes befassen zu
dürfen und dann wird auch die opposition
hier grüne und linke feststellen dass es
ein äußerst dynamisch angelegte system
ist weil ja jedes jahr höhere
anschluss raten haben werden im
universaldienst ihre kolleginnen
kollegen es ist auch jetzt eine gute
gelegenheit danke zu sagen an alle die
mitgemacht haben die arbeitsebene der
ministerien verbände unternehmen
bundesrat die mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter unserer fraktion und
insbesondere danke ich an dieser stelle
meiner mitarbeiterin anna rosenberg die
hervorragende arbeit geleistet hat ohne
sie wäre das für mich nicht möglich
gewesen
vielen dank ein gutes gesetz sie können
gigabit mäßig zustimmen dankeschön
ja ist das herz von der spd mit fernglas
phase rung und einer prise parteipolitik
der voraussichtliche vor der abstimmung
über das telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz ist jetzt hansjörg
durz von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
jetzt kann er ans rednerpult
sehr geehrter herr präsident für die
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
die erde ist komplett vernetzt alle
völker haben gigabit netze errichtet
flächendruck flächendeckender mobilfunk
und schnelles glasfasernetz sind
standard auf der ganzen welt auf der
ganzen welt ein gar nicht ganz so
kleines folge im herzen europas
kommuniziert noch immer über alte kupfer
oder koaxialkabel und betreibt eine
sportart die andernorts längst
ausgestorben ist sie schmeißt zwar nicht
mit hinkelstein im betreibt aber
funkloch hopping die gallier asterix und
obelix waren nur dank eines zaubertranks
fähig auf augenhöhe mit den
fortschrittlicheren römern zu sein damit
deutschland nicht den anschluss bei der
digitalen infrastruktur verliert hat
diese koalition viel in dieser
legislatur getan aber auch wir brauchen
einen zaubertrank für den ausbau der
digitalen installer infrastruktur das
rezept dafür
legen wir mit diesem gesetz vor
deutschlands weg in die gigabit
gesellschaft ist mit diesem gesetz damit
abgedeckt
das staubige nebenkosten privileg aus
den 80ern des letzten jahrhunderts haben
wir zur bundesweiten förderung von
inhouse glasfasernetzen umgestaltet es
schafft den rahmen dafür dass millionen
von wohnungen für glasfaser werden
können wer behauptet lobbyinteressen
hätten sich hier zu lasten der mieter
durchgesetzt hatte das gesetz entweder
nicht genau angeschaut oder es nicht
genau verstanden
aufgrund aufgrund von open access
wahlfreiheit und wettbewerb wird die
gesamtbelastung der mieter nicht höher
als beim alten nebenkosten privileg für
fünf euro und liebe kollegin rösner dies
sind gedeckelt diese fünf euro für fünf
euro im monat kann der mieter in den
nächsten sechs jahren einen
glasfaseranschluss in seiner wohnung
erhalten
dieses förderinstrument zündet den
glasfaser turbo für deutschland wer
hingegen zum politischen hauptziel
erklärt mieter vor jeglicher beteiligung
zu schützen er verschweigt dass der
preis bei einer fehlenden umlage für den
mieter deutlich höher liegen würde
denn die meisten würden dann auf
absehbare zeit ein dasein im digitalen
gallischen dorf fristen
gleiches gleiches gilt im übrigen für
die kritik am universaldienst der
grundversorgung kollege lange hat es
dargestellt
ein zahnloser tiger so heißt es doch wer
so denkt kann demokratische strukturen
nicht gering schätzen denn ist ist
niemand geringeres
als der verkehrsausschuss dieses hauses
der mit der die mindestbandbreite
künftig endgültig feststellen wird
ich jedenfalls glaube an die fähigkeit
unserer demokratie und unserer
parlamentarier
ich freue mich darüber dass wir den
konflikt über die vertragslaufzeiten
beilegen konnten das ist ein gewinn für
den mündigen verbraucher der nun
weiterhin selbstbestimmt zwischen ein
und zwei jahres verträge wählen kann wir
haben auch weiteres beim
verbraucherschutz getan zum beispiel
dass eine störung innerhalb von zwei
kalender tagen behoben werden müssen
drückt den zugang zum netz in die nähe
eine daseinsvorsorge und da gehört er im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert auch hin
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen bei
allen die daran mitgearbeitet haben es
ist ein wirklich gutes gesetz vielen
dank
oder dass jetzt gleich acht bestimmt
wird sogar den support von der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion zweite unsere lösung
heißt das gesetz wird verabschiedet und
lehre an den bundestagspräsidenten zu
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
umsetzung der richtlinie 20 18 1972 des
europäischen parlaments und des rates
vom 11 dezember 20 18 über den
europäischen kodex für die elektronische
kommunikation und zur modernisierung des
telekommunikationsrechts der ausschuss
für energie wirtschaft und energie
immobilien zahlen haben uns empfehlung
auf der drucksache 28 8 65 den
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung auf
drucksachen 26 10 8 und 26 90 4 in der
ausschuss fassung anzunehmen ich bin
diejenige die mit setzten daraufhin der
us fassung zu sehen wollen um das
handzeichen das in die
koalitionsfraktionen der stimmt dagegen
dass die opposition wäre enthält sich
neben der gesetzentwurf ist damit in
zweiter beratung angenommen
wir kommen zu dritten beratung und
abstimmung ich bin diejenige die den
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben sagen
wer stimmt dagegen enthält sich dann
gesehen
der gesetzentwurf ist damit mit den
stimmen der koalition gegen die stimmen
der opposition angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 10 b wir setzen die
abstimmungen zu dem beschluss des
ausschusses für wirtschaft und energie
auf drucksache 28 8 65 fort der
ausschuss empfiehlt unter buchstabe b
seiner beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung
des antrags der fraktion der fdp auf der
drucksache 16 sogar in der
oppositionsfraktion zum laufenden
gesetzt für die empfehlung auf d die
linke bündnis die grünen sind dagegen
die fdp die wissens empfehlung ist damit
angenommen unter buchstabe c empfiehlt
der ausschuss die ablehnung des antrags
der fraktion bündnis 90 grünen auf der
drucksache 26 5 31 mit dem titel
telekommunikations modernisierungsgesetz
grundversorgung garantieren und digitale
infrastruktur ausbauen
wer stimmt für diese mission empfehlung
kreationen die fdp wirft ihm dagegen
würden also auch hier wieder die
erklärung dass das gegenstimme die leute
die grünen wollen das eigentlich als
vertrag umsetzen aber es ist
mehrheitlich abgelehnt worden
es empfiehlt weiterhin und der buchstabe
d seiner 15
die ablehnung des antrags der fraktion
bündnis 90 grünen auf der drucksache 26
532 mit dem titel telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz den schutz von
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern in den
mittelpunkt stellen er stimmt für diese
mission empfehlung
koalition fdp afd wer stimmt dagegen die
grünen bündnis 90 die linke die
empfehlung ist damit angenommen und
schließlich empfiehlt der ausschuss
unter buchstabe e seiner
beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion die grünen auf der
drucksache 65 26 5 33 mit dem titel
krieg um telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz datenschutz
it-sicherheit und bürgerrechte sichern
wer stimmt für diese mission
empfehlungen afc fdp bestimmt dagegen
bündnis 90 die grünen wollen und landrat
ist es im vertrags der bundes grünen
abgelehnt tagesordnungspunkt 10 bis
empfehlung des ausschusses für inneres
und heimat zu dem antrag der fraktion
der fdp mit dem titel recht auf
verschlüsselung privatsphäre und
sicherheit im digitalen raum stärken
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
27 3 25 den antrag der fraktion der fdp
auf der drucksache 5764 abzulehnen
er stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
kfd das team dagegen die fdp die übrigen
fraktionen der beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen bisher sind wegen des
ausschusses für verkehr
tagesordnungspunkt 10 ehe und die
verkehr und digitale infrastruktur zum
antrag der fraktion der fdp mit dem
titel regeln für den schnellstart ins
gigabit zeitalter der ausschuss
empfiehlt die zahl der bewertungen auf
drucksache 28 4 28 den antrag der
fraktion der fdp auf der drucksache 26
188 abzunehmen
er stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
es steht dagegen
wendt hält sich auch dieser antrag der
fdp suchen gegen wort bei enthaltung der
asd gegen die stimmen der fdp die stimme
des übrigen hauses angenommen
die beschlussempfehlung
tagesordnungspunkt 10 f des ausschusses
für verkehr und digitale infrastruktur
zum antrag der fraktion die linke mit
dem titel recht auf schnelles internet
für alle
der ausschuss empfiehlt einen beschluss
den verkauf der drucksache 28 8 76 den
antrag der fraktion die linke auf der
drucksache 27 192 abzulehnen
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
wer stimmt dagegen die beere enthält
sich die beschlussempfehlung ist gegen
die stimmen der fraktion die linke die
bei enthaltung von bündnis 90 die grünen
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
angenommen und damit natürlich die
sieben anträge der oppositionsfraktionen
zum telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz abgelehnt worden
der gesetzentwurf ist beschlossen